well we have had it confirmed from
Downing Street this afternoon that the
government is pushing to cut a deal with
the EU over the issue of these tariffs
trying to reduce the kind of Cliff Edge
impact which the car manufacturers are
so worried about the Prime Minister
himself is on the plane on the way to
Japan for the G7 a pack of traveling
reporters are with Him including our
political editor Beth Rigby and they
asked the Prime Minister what he makes
of these concerns from the car companies
about the issue of brexit these calls to
renegotiate the deal and also broader
concerns about the impact on the economy
including Nigel farage saying he
believes that brexit has been a failure
the Prime Minister hit back at this
pretty passionately by the sounds of
things insisting that he voted for
brexit that he believes in brexit and
that as prime minister he insists he is
delivering on the economic brexit
benefits as well he gave a whole list of
what those are including he claims uh
Freeport
deregulation of financial services and
also he says there are plans which we've
heard a lot of talk about recently to
reform the working time directive he
insists that that will save UK
businesses billions of pounds he also
talks about reforming and repealing 2
000 pieces of EU retained law which is a
very delicate matter for the Prime
Minister because when he was campaigning
to be leader of the party he did
actually pledge to scrap or 4 000 pieces
of legislation there was a u-turn on
that last week which many of his back
benches are extremely angry about but
the government effectively realized he
didn't have time to deliver that he also
gave a very upbeat narrative on the
economy overall to reporters
um talking about a survey recently
carried out by some 4 000 CEOs who said
the UK was their number one Investment
location in Europe
um the fact that in Japan he's going to
be announcing uh plans for 18 billion
pounds in Investments I think that's
rather optimistic given that we know
from the latest figures that the UK
economy shrank by 0.3 in March and is
the only one of the G7 which hasn't
recovered it's pre-pandemic level he was
also asked about Liz Trust his trip to
Taiwan which she helpfully made just on
the eve of his trip to the uh to Japan
um that clearly is quite concerning for
Downing streets a very delicate part of
the world and it's not necessarily very
helpful to have a former pre- prime
minister freelancing on foreign policy
but he seemed fairly not unconcerned by
that and just reiterated the line that
the UK has a strong alliance with other
countries in its position on Taiwan